À la fin du XVᵉ siècle,
deux navigateurs portugais
s'approchent d'îles inconnues.
Perdue au croisement de l'équateur
et du méridien de Greenwich,
l'archipel de Sao Tomé et Principe
apparaît comme un mirage
au milieu de l'océan.
Ce territoire baigne
au creux de l'Afrique de l'Ouest,
au large du Gabon.
Pendant des siècles,
ce bout de terre a été la plaque tournante
de la traite
des esclaves et du travail forcé.
Sur d'immenses plantations,
l'empire a imposé
un système d'exploitation
de la canne à sucre,
puis du café
et surtout du cacao.
Les colons portugais
ont quitté Sao Tomé en 1975,
laissant derrière eux des fantômes.
Les élégantes bâtissent
des exploitations agricoles,
elles, sont restées.
Elles plient
sous le poids du passé.
On les appelle ici les Roças.
Quand on plonge entre leurs murs décrépis,
les souvenirs resurgissent.
Leurs noms bucoliques
tranchent avec leur histoire.
Porto Alegre, Fraternidade,
Novo Destino, Saudade.
Des centaines de familles
s'y sont réfugiées aujourd'hui.
Nous sommes partis à leur rencontre
découvrir ces habitants tiraillés
entre cet héritage encombrant
et un avenir
qu'ils tentent de construire.
Sous l'ère coloniale,
les Portugais ont importé
le théâtre pour se divertir.
Les esclaves Santoméens
se sont réappropriés les codes
au fil du temps.
Et on en fait un art burlesque unique
au monde, le tchiloli.
Je vous présente tout mon respect,
mon ami Infante Valdovino.
Et moi, je vous présente mon respect
et ma confiance.
Je suis venu
pour vous inviter à la chasse.
-Quand ?
-Maintenant.
Monpage, occupe-toi des chevaux
pendant la chasse.
Cette pièce débute par un meurtre
au cœur de la forêt.
L'assassin est riche,
influent et intouchable.
Il symbolise le maître
qui possède tous les droits.
La victime, elle,
représente le peuple asservi.
Derrière ses airs carnavalesques,
le tchiloli est en fait
un long plaidoyer pour la justice
et une dénonciation de l'esclavage.
Ce spectacle nous raconte l'histoire
de Sao Tomé et Principe.
L'histoire d'un peuple
qui dépasse sa condition et qui se libère.
Aujourd'hui émancipé
du joug portugais,
ce peuple africain parviendra-t-il enfin
à panser les plaies de la colonisation
et prendre son destin en main ?
Je m'appelle Herlander.
Mon nom de famille est Chantre.
Les cours de capoeira,
je suis connu comme Pandeled.
J'ai 27 ans
et j'habite à Boa Entrada.
C'est ici, dans cette Roça,
que je donne mes cours.
J'habite là depuis cinq ans.
C'est la capoeira
qui m'a amené ici.
Voir des enfants
qui veulent apprendre la capoeira,
c'est ce qui me motive le plus.
Quand l'un d'entre eux vient me voir
et me dit Pande,
apprenez-moi, moi,
je ne peux pas lui refuser.
Alors je le prends dans le groupe.
Moi, j'ai tout appris avec mon professeur.
Et c'est pour cela
que pour être un bon entraîneur,
il faut apprendre à travailler
avant tout avec les enfants.
Ça, c'était la maison
où habitaient les seigneurs,
les maîtres,
il y a très longtemps.
Avec le temps, les gens d'ici ont commencé
à utiliser certaines pièces de la maison
pour ne pas les laisser à l'abandon.
Ils ont commencé à les investir.
C'est comme ça
que tout a commencé.
Il faut mettre l'éducation
par-dessus tout.
Ne pas manquer
de respect aux anciens.
Respecter son père
et sa mère à la maison.
Tout ça fait partie
des enseignements de la capoeira.
La capoeira sert à éduquer.
Par exemple, il est inimaginable
qu'un élève
vienne à manquer
de respect à qui que ce soit.
Ce n'est
pas possible.
L'avenir, il n'y a que Dieu
qu'il connaisse.
Tout est entre ses mains.
Moi, tout ce que je veux faire,
je le fais pour cette génération
et pour la génération future.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
je m'en remets à Dieu.
Je m'appelle Raï Lopes,
j'ai treize ans.
Mon père est moto-taxi.
Et ma mère est vendeuse.
Elle est commerçante.
Moi, j'aime écouter
de la musique.
J'ai joué du berimbau.
Mon nom de capoeira
est Salvajem.
Mon professeur
m'a donné ce surnom,
car il a vu que j'avais le même style
qu'un autre élève brésilien
qui porte ce nom.
Mon mouvement préféré
est la race Terras doupla.
Il faut fermer les pieds
avant de retomber au sol.
Ça, c'est cool.
Moi, je voudrais voyager
en faisant de la capoeira.
Les Roças sont de grandes plantations
constituées
de terres cultivées et d'habitations
construites sur les lieux
même de production.
Elles visaient l'autosuffisance
et sont devenues
avec le temps de véritables communautés.
Les élégantes maisons des patrons
et contremaîtres,
inoccupés depuis l'indépendance en 1975,
contrastent avec les Comboios.
Ces bâtiments étroits
et alignés ou habités,
les ouvriers de la Roça
encore aujourd'hui.
C'est ici que vit Raï avec sa famille.
Raï, vient.
Il faut aller à l'école.
Sao Tomé et Principe
réapprend à se construire
et mise beaucoup
sur la nouvelle génération.
Le pays est un État jeune.
Près de la moitié
de la population a moins de 20 ans.
Ces enfants de paysans
ou de petits commerçants comme Raï,
quittent leur Roça chaque demi-journée
pour s'instruire, lire ou compter.
Le taux de scolarisation de l'île atteint
quasiment les 100 % à l'école primaire.
C'est quoi comme cours aujourd'hui ?
Maths et français.
Ah non, pas français, écologie.
Moi, je suis meilleur
que lui en géographie.
Qui sait qui est meilleur en géographie ?
Toi, tu es meilleur que moi ?
En capoeira,
c'est vrai, c'est lui le meilleur.
Bonne après-midi à tous.
Asseyez-vous.
Que savez-vous
sur l'esclavage à Sao Tomé ?
L'esclavage, est-ce que c'est
un mot difficile ?
Est-ce un mot
dont vous maîtrisez le sens ?
Raï, dis-nous, que sais-tu ?
Vas-y.
C'était un travail très dur
et en échange,
il n'y avait pas de salaire ni rien.
Ils étaient tout le temps affamés
et s'ils s'arrêtaient de travailler,
c'était des coups de fouet.
OK, merci.
Continuons.
On va encore parler
de Sao Tomé et Principe.
Vous savez qu'il existait
différents types de Roças :
Roça Augustinho Neto,
Roça Boa Entrada,
Roça Bellavista.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'une Roça ?
C'est quoi exactement ça ?
La Roça, c'était ce que les Portugais
utilisaient pour faire tourner
les plantations de cacao
et les plantations de café.
C'était les lieux ou les Portugais
plantaient le café et le cacao.
Mais comment étaient ces plantations ?
Était-ce des petits
ou des grands domaines ?
De par sa situation géographique,
les puissances européennes
ont fait de Sao
Tomé un laboratoire dès le XVᵉ siècle.
L'homme noir exploité
dans la canne à sucre,
une première dans l'histoire.
Le modèle sera reproduit
dans toute la Caraïbe.
Jusqu'au XIXᵉ siècle,
l'ensemble de la société
repose sur le commerce de captifs,
pendant que les Portugais
règnent en maîtres
sur la traite négrière mondiale.
Ces décennies
marqueront le pays au fer rouge.
Une fois l'esclavage aboli, en 1876,
l'Empire a besoin de nouveaux bras
pour cultiver ses territoires exotiques.
Des travailleurs sous-contrat
viennent d'Angola, du Mozambique
et du Cap Vert
pour désormais cultiver le café
et surtout le cacao.
Ces serviteurs, comme on les appelle ici,
travaillent plus de 14h par jour
dans des conditions
de labeur extrême.
Une main-d'œuvre corvéable à merci.
Le système est si efficace qu'au début
du siècle dernier, Sao Tomé et Principe
devient le premier exportateur
de cacao au monde.
Voilà l'amertume que cache
le doux surnom des îles chocolat.
Mais la communauté internationale critique
cet esclavage dissimulé
et le Portugal doit
rendre des comptes.
Pour redorer son image,
il construit dans les Roças des écoles,
des églises
et surtout des hôpitaux.
Des structures inimaginables
dans le reste de l'Afrique
qui fonctionnent
jusqu'à l'indépendance du pays.
Depuis, elles subissent inexorablement
les affres du temps
et la nature semble prendre
possession de ces ruines.
Le chemin du train passait par là
et jusqu'à Quintal.
C'est le chemin privé
de la Roça Boa Entrada.
La richesse des pauvres de Sao Tomé,
c'est le cacao et le café.
Quand les gens ont envie
de manger du cacao,
ils viennent le cueillir
et le manger.
Quand c'est le moment de la cueillette,
les gens viennent,
ils coupent le cacao en deux
et le vendent.
C'est notre richesse,
comme un diamant brut.
Je suis Luis Mario Almeida.
Je suis Santoméen.
Je suis née en 1961.
Mais son enfance,
c'était la fin de l'ère coloniale.
Avant, c'était l'époque des Portugais.
Après, il y a eu l'indépendance.
Et moi, j'étais encore assez jeune.
Donc mon enfance a été une enfance
d'une certaine façon triste
et heureuse à la fois.
Je dis triste
parce qu'à cette époque-là,
nous étions fils d'immigrés
venus travailler sous contrat.
On vivait dans une Roça.
Notre maison était toute petite.
Il y avait un contraste avec le patron
qui avait une grande maison
et peu d'enfants.
Nous, nous étions une famille nombreuse.
Mes parents dormaient
dans un grand lit
et nous, avec mes frères,
nous dormions par terre.
Mes parents sont arrivés
dans les années 50.
Mon père était analphabète.
Il n'a jamais su me dire
quel était son âge et qui était son père.
Il n'a jamais su dire
qui était sa mère.
ce qu'il a amené à Sao Tomé.
De nombreux Capverdiens
qui fuyaient la sécheresse
et la pauvreté de leur pays
ont remplacé les esclaves,
dans les Roças de Sao Tomé.
La plupart ne sont jamais rentrés.
La Roça était structurée.
Il y avait les grandes Roças
des grandes compagnies
et des plus petites
de moyennes entreprises.
À un moment donné,
il n'y avait plus suffisamment de Forros.
La main-d'œuvre locale.
Donc pour beaucoup de Roças,
à l'époque des contrats,
on en faisait venir du Cap-Vert,
d'Angola et du Mozambique.
Les Roças étaient organisées
de telle manière.
Le siège où se trouvait l'administrateur,
la comptabilité
et tout le système de gestion
et les gros entrepôts.
Il y avait des dépendances
qui étaient
des plus petites exploitations,
entre 50 et 300 hectares
avec environ 300 travailleurs
gérés par un maître
et un contremaître différent
pour les hommes et les femmes.
Ces Roças se produisaient le cacao
et le café,
qui ensuite étaient transférés
au siège central pour être traités,
séchés et enfin exportés.
Je suis directeur exécutif
d'une coopérative
d'exportation de café biologique.
L'univers du café
me passionne depuis toujours.
Petit, je venais là
pour être en contact
avec le café et les producteurs,
et je posais des tas de questions.
Ces petits wagons apportaient le cacao,
de la fermentation au séchage.
J'ai joué ici.
J'ai connu cet endroit rempli de cafés.
Les gens travaillaient beaucoup d'heures
sans interruption.
Pour s'occuper du four,
il y en a même qui dormaient ici.
Ils ne faisaient que travailler.
Les conditions de travail, vous savez,
elles étaient proches de l'exploitation.
J'ai connu une dame qui habitait ici
pendant l'époque coloniale.
Elle travaillait
dans la maison du patron.
Et quand elle est revenue ici longtemps,
après qu'elle était si triste
de voir tout ça en ruines,
qu'elle en a pleuré.
Et elle a décidé
de ne plus jamais revenir à Monté Café.
C'est normal que l'on puisse
être aussi choqué.
D'une certaine manière,
nos parents n'ont pas perdu d'argent,
mais ils ont donné leur sang pour tout ça,
pour construire tout ça.
Et nous,
on le laisse se dégrader ?
Les Santoméens ont laissé derrière eux
des siècles de travail forcé
et aujourd'hui tentent
de se réapproprier les lieux.
Mais il leur faut du temps,
car les stigmates de la colonisation
demeurent dans les Roças,
dans les champs
comme dans les esprits.
Combien de kilos
tu penses ramasser ?
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
en tout, je pense pouvoir
faire jusqu'à 500 kilos.
Oui, minimum 500.
C'est même possible
que je dépasse les 500 kilos.
Si c'est le cas,
c'est bon pour nous.
Le premier jour,
j'ai très peu ramassé.
Le deuxième jour,
j'ai dû faire environ 20 kilos
et aujourd'hui,
j'ai encore fait un sac là-bas.
Ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui,
on va approcher les 70 kilos.
En ce moment, on est l'un
des plus importants
producteurs de café robusta
et arabica.
Je coordonne l'équipe
composée de techniciens agricoles.
Le technicien doit apprendre
aux agriculteurs
comment bien cueillir le café.
Par exemple, on doit cueillir uniquement
du café bien mûr.
Il ne faut pas
cueillir du café vert,
parce que ça peut nuire
à toute la production.
Les conditions de vie des gens
qui travaillent dans les Roças
étaient très difficiles.
Comme mes copains
commençaient à travailler
dès l'âge de sept ans,
ils sont pour la plupart
analphabètes aujourd'hui.
Moi, j'ai eu la chance
d'être allé au lycée agricole.
Je voulais devenir maître ou contremaître.
Ça m'a vraiment marqué,
car la discipline
y était quasi militaire.
Je veux dire, on portait
les uniformes de la guerre du Biafra.
Les uniformes donnés
par les Portugais.
Il y a beaucoup de café vert là.
Ce café est prêt ?
Oui, celui-là est bon.
Mais il y a trop de café vert.
Vous ne l'avez pas vu ?
Certains producteurs sont jeunes
et n'ont pas encore appris
à faire une bonne sélection.
Il y a des variétés
qui mûrissent plus vite que d'autres.
Parfois, ils confondent
la variété jaune avec la verte.
Ça arrive
qu'ils fassent cette erreur.
Nous nous cultivons du café noir
dans un environnement sain.
C'est une culture biologique
sans utilisation de produits chimiques.
On le traite avec l'eau d'ici.
C'est de l'eau potable
et de bonne qualité.
Et autre chose,
notre café est cultivé
sur des terres volcaniques.
Tous ces facteurs sont déterminants pour
obtenir une excellente qualité de café.
Obo, ça vient du mot français le bois.
Car vous savez qu'ici,
il y avait une colonie française, non ?
Et c'est ici,
ce parc au bout que nous considérons
être l'âme de Sao Tomé.
Parce que c'est la source de l'eau,
de la pluie, des aliments.
On y trouve aussi des médicaments.
Et c'est dans ce même parc
que nos croyances sont nées.
Les gens avaient peur de l'Obo,
car c'est ici que vivaient les fugitifs.
Les fugitifs étaient ceux
qui étaient venus travailler sous contrat.
Et d'autres qui avaient été capturés
en Angola, en Zambie, Au Mozambique.
Mais, ils n'avaient pas accepté
l'esclavage ni le fait d'être maltraités.
Donc ils se sont opposés
aux ordres des colons et se sont enfuis.
Ils vivaient dans la forêt.
Une forêt inaccessible, éloignée.
Et ils étaient poursuivis
par la police portugaise.
À l'époque, ma génération
a été une des dernières
à croiser encore des fugitifs.
On pensait qu'ils étaient méchants,
qu'ils se réfugient dans les bois,
qu'ils voulaient nous tuer,
nous violer.
Et à cause tout ça,
tout le monde avait peur.
Et il y avait des endroits,
où on nous disait,
faites attention là-bas,
les fugitifs dorment.
Du coup, les gens passaient
par là avec crainte.
On ne connaissait pas leur histoire,
ni la raison de leur fuite.
On voulait nous faire croire
qu'ils étaient dangereux et violents.
Mais en réalité,
ils étaient courageux.
Parce que pour vivre retranché
dans une forêt comme celle-ci sans rien,
il faut avoir du courage.
Le 12 juillet 1975,
la colonisation prend fin
et Sao Tomé proclame
son indépendance.
Le nouveau pouvoir en place
instaure un régime marxiste.
Il nationalise les plantations
et distribue les parcelles aux habitants.
Un vent de liberté souffle
sur tout le pays.
Mais l'euphorie est de courte durée.
La planification de l'économie
et une distribution
des terres déséquilibrée
creusent les inégalités sociales
et nuisent à la production.
En dix ans, l'exportation
de cacao est divisée par trois.
Le communisme santoméen ne fonctionne pas
et la paysannerie
en est la grande perdante.
L'État décide donc
de libéraliser l'économie.
Depuis, le plus petit pays d'Afrique
fait le difficile apprentissage
de la mondialisation.
Cette situation économiquement fragile
ne favorise pas toujours
la liberté d'expression.
Le chanteur Augusto et son groupe,
les descendants
en ont fait l'amère expérience.
Je suis originaire d'ici.
José Augusto Pereira Vieira,
chanteur du groupe Les Descendants.
Mais en plus de la musique,
j'ai rêvé de faire de la politique
ou de devenir
un représentant de ce pays.
Nous, les descendants,
nous avions comme objectif
d'aider la société en tant que jeunes,
d'agir dans l'éducation,
dans le domaine de l'instruction.
On a essayé
d'attirer l'attention du gouvernement
pour qu'il se concentre davantage
sur le peuple, sur la jeunesse.
On voulait aider.
La musique sert à ça.
Aider le gouvernement à prendre
conscience de ce qui ne va pas.
Nous sommes comme des députés,
des représentants culturels,
de la nation, du peuple.
On est là pour faire
passer un message.
Les musiciens ici
n'ont pas de ressources ni de moyens.
Il n'y a pas de grosses scènes.
C'est dur de gagner de l'argent.
Alors nous nous sommes serré la ceinture
pour mettre de l'argent de côté.
On a réuni toutes nos économies.
On est parti au Portugal
pour enregistrer un disque.
Fichez le camp!
Ce disque a eu la malchance
de sortir pile au moment des élections
parce qu'ici, ce n'est pas la France,
ce n'est pas l'Europe.
Il n'y a pas de liberté d'expression ici,
c'est l'Afrique, c'est une île.
Après cette chanson,
on a eu des retours négatifs,
ça a été mal interprété.
Nous n'avons plus eu
les mêmes opportunités que par le passé.
Avant, nous étions un groupe
tout le temps invité lors de spectacles,
d'événements, dans des fêtes.
À partir de là, on n'a plus vraiment eu
de vraie opportunité.
Les gens nous demandent, qu'est-ce qui
se passe avec votre groupe ?
Vous ne faites plus de disques ?
Vous ne jouez plus ?
Si, en fait, on joue toujours,
mais on n'a plus la chance de se produire.
Il faut nettoyer toute cette canne à sucre
et ce bananier.
On a appris cela avec nos ancêtres.
Moi, j'ai appris avec mon grand-père
sur son champ de canne à sucre.
J'ai appris la fabrication de l'eau de vie
avec mes amis Johnson, Folia, Loulou.
Ils avaient déjà un champ à eux
et moi j'étais le dernier
à en acquérir un peu.
Ils m'ont encouragé à en chercher.
Je suis content aujourd'hui.
En plus de mon métier à la télévision,
il y a toujours le travail des champs.
C'est de là que tout est parti pour nous,
les descendants.
À l'époque,
on n'avait pas d'argent
pour enregistrer un disque.
On réunissait l'argent que chacun gagnait
grâce au travail des champs.
On devait couper de la canne à sucre
pour en faire de l'eau de vie,
pour pouvoir sortir notre premier,
notre deuxième et notre troisième morceau.
On a réuni l'argent
grâce au commerce de l'eau de vie
pour pouvoir
enregistrer les instrumentaux.
Mes grands-parents, à l'époque,
ont été amenés ici
pour travailler à la Roça Rio Do Ouro.
Ma mère avait six ans.
C'est ici que mon père
et ma mère se sont rencontrés.
Ils sont tombés amoureux, se sont mariés.
Voici pourquoi je suis ici.
José Augusto Pereira Vieira,
plus connu comme Augusto d'Agostinho Neto,
de la Roça Agostinho Neto.
Oh, voilà mon père.
C'est mon père et ma mère.
Ma mère a été
le pilier de mon éducation.
C'est elle qui m'a tout donné.
Qui a travaillé dur dans les Roças,
dans le cacao, dans les plantations,
pour pouvoir m'envoyer à l'école,
pour payer les factures,
mes vêtements, mes chaussures.
Non seulement à moi,
mais à tous mes frères.
Ma mère est vraiment le pilier.
Elle est tout dans ma vie.
Ici, il y a toutes les archives
de mon histoire musicale
et personnelle
de mon groupe, "Les descendants",
de ma famille.
Ces histoires non seulement sont celles
de ma mère et de mon père,
mais aussi celles de la Roça.
L'histoire des gens
qui sont venus sous contrat,
l'histoire du quotidien.
Tout cela a contribué à développer
encore plus ma passion pour la musique.
C'est tout cela qui m'a poussé à écrire.
Nous avons fait des morceaux qui parlent
de l'histoire et de l'immigration.
Voici l'ancienne Roça Agostinho Neto
avec ma tante et mon oncle.
Regardez comme
elle était belle à l'époque.
Mais moi, je rêve un jour avant de mourir,
de la voir à nouveau comme cela.
On est sur le chemin de l'hôpital.
Là où étaient soignés
les malades de cette Roça.
Mais c'était aussi l'un
des plus importants hôpitaux du pays.
Le célèbre et triste
hôpital où je suis né.
Où tous mes collègues
des descendants sont nés.
Où dans les années 80-90,
on est quasiment tous
les jeunes de Sao Tomé.
Les Portugais sont partis brutalement
après l'indépendance.
Il n'y a pas eu de période de transition
et aucun personnel qualifié n'est resté
pour faire fonctionner
les grandes infrastructures du pays.
Même s'il était
un symbole de la colonisation,
l'Hôpital d'Agostinho Neto était considéré
comme un monument national
par les Santoméens.
Désormais,
c'est un immense édifice en ruine.
C'est très triste.
Quand je rentre ici,
ça me donne envie de pleurer.
Je vois cet hôpital où je suis né,
où j'ai grandi.
J'ai vu tellement de choses.
Ça me donne envie de pleurer.
C'est très triste, vraiment.
Je me souviens
quand j'avais douze, treize, quatorze ans.
J'ai été hospitalisé ici
à cause de la malaria.
Ce n'est pas un mauvais souvenir,
car j'ai été bien soigné
avec de bons traitements.
Et heureusement,
en trois ou quatre jours, j'étais guéri.
Et c'est pour ça que ça me rend triste
de le voir dans cet état.
Dans le passé,
il y avait une structure qui fonctionnait
et qui s'occupait
d'entretenir notre patrimoine public.
Il y avait du travail.
Les gens étaient occupés
dans les plantations,
dans les champs de canne à sucre.
Bref, il y avait du boulot.
Aujourd'hui, regardez
dans quel état c'est. Qui en voudrait ?
C'est pour cette raison que
les gens comparent le présent et le passé.
Aujourd'hui, on a des avantages
que l'on n'avait pas à l'époque.
Mais pour moi, il y a de bonnes choses
à prendre dans le passé.
La musique vient de l'âme.
J'écoutais de la musique à la maison
grâce à mes parents.
Mon père, à l'époque,
avait un tourne-disque
et il écoutait beaucoup
de musique capverdienne.
Moi, je l'avais déjà dans l'âme.
J'aimais déjà cette musique.
Ensuite, j'ai commencé le catéchisme
dans une église catholique,
où tous les enfants,
moi le premier, ont été choristes.
C'est là qu'on a appris la subtilité
du chant des notes.
C'est là qu'on a pris confiance.
On s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait du talent
et qu'on devait
en faire quelque chose.
Salut, comment tu vas ?
On est amis depuis l'enfance
et on aimait déjà jouer
des petits morceaux avec des guitares,
avec des cordes de bananier.
C'est là qu'est né notre amour
pour la musique.
Le groupe est composé de cinq éléments.
On s'appelle les descendants,
car nous sommes
des enfants de parents Capverdiens,
de parents Angolais
et d'autres de parents Santoméens.
On essaye de reprendre celle
qu'on faisait avec les descendants.
Dans le sud de l'île
se trouve le royaume des Angolares.
Les Angolares seraient
les descendants directs
d'esclaves affranchis.
Ce peuple a toujours refusé la servitude
face à l'autorité portugaise
et s'est tenu à l'écart
du système des Roças,
ce qui lui a valu
une réputation rebelle et libre,
voire même un peu sauvage,
une sorte de village d'irréductibles
très attaché à son bonheur.
Aujourd'hui, cette communauté
de pêcheurs vit pacifiquement
sur la côte sud-ouest du pays.
Je m'appelle Aladim Dos Santos,
surnommé Didi.
J'ai 36 ans.
Ici, on est à Porto Alegre.
Alors pourquoi ce nom ?
Parce que c'est une localité
qui apporte l'allégresse, le bonheur.
C'est pour ça
qu'elle s'appelle Porto Alegre.
J'ai commencé à pêcher,
quand j'avais douze ans,
quand j'ai eu seize ans,
j'ai commencé la pêche en apnée.
Mes grands-parents m'ont raconté ce qui
se passait à l'époque de l'esclavage.
Au départ, je me suis senti triste.
Mais juste après,
j'ai eu un sentiment de peur aussi.
Les deux sentiments ne faisaient qu'un,
la peur et la tristesse.
Parce que ça me fait vraiment
de la peine d'entendre ces histoires,
des gens qui ont travaillé
à cette époque.
Les gens travaillaient
et ils sacrifiaient tout.
Et personnellement,
je pense que les habitants de Sao
Tomé doivent être libres.
Ils doivent avoir un emploi.
Mais ils doivent être libres
aujourd'hui, avant tout.